a government source tells CBS news a
maker of oxycontin could file for
bankruptcy as early as today Purdue
Pharma and its owners members of the
Sackler family have been negotiating a
potential settlement for months over
Purdue's alleged role in fueling the
nationwide opioid epidemic mola leggies
that produce headquarters that's in
Stanford Connecticut with more on this
story mola what could this mean
good morning well good morning Gail a
bankruptcy filing could mean smaller
payouts for plaintiffs in more than 2000
lawsuits against the company now a
source close to the negotiations tell
CBS News that Purdue will file for
bankruptcy
if those plaintiffs don't accept the
settlement deal by today and as of
yesterday those negotiations were still
ongoing
Richard Sackler and members of his
family who own Purdue Pharma could pay
up to four and a half billion dollars as
part of a settlement connected to the
opioid epidemic that's according to a
source close to the negotiation between
Purdue Pharma and state attorneys
general Sackler family members could
also give up ownership of the
pharmaceutical company as part of the
deal Stanford University law professor
George Tree antis what the negotiations
continue to hinge on seems to be the
contribution of the Sackler defendants
but Pennsylvania Attorney General Josh
Shapiro told CBS News yesterday the
Sackler have not put a sufficient offer
on the table and our negotiations have
stalled Purdue had no comment when asked
if negotiations had hit a wall Purdue is
accused of fueling the nation's opioid
crisis by allegedly downplaying the
addictive nature of its popular drug
oxycontin according to the CDC
46 people die every day from overdoses
linked to prescription opioids Purdue
when the Sackler family deny allegations
they helped engineer the crisis in one
case Purdue called accusations a rush to
vilify the drug maker this drug amuses
the patient not the patient abusing the
drug five years ago tony la greca lost
his son 41 year old Matthew to a
methadone overdose he says Matthew
started taking opioids for a football
injury in the 90s and became hooked
what does justice look like for you
Richard sac was behind
baaz and the family's broke why do they
get to keep all this money and have such
a nice life in my life I don't have my
son anymore
well source close to the negotiations
tells us that Perdue the pharmaceutical
giant here has been considering filing
bankruptcy since last March now the
company is set to stand trial in Ohio
next month for its alleged role in that
state's opioid epidemic Anthony right
molar we'll be keeping an eye on that
thank you